here is something just unbelievable this
is I don't even
Donald J Trump what do you think of that
sounds like an insult right sounds like
something that detractors of Trump would
say Greg stuby a republican congressman
who has made the decision against the
wishes of Florida Republicans to come
out and endorse Trump now went on
Newsmax his big announcement and he says
I am proud to endorse Donald Trump
yeah and Rob I want to thank you for
giving me the opportunity to talk about
this on your show and I'm happy and
honored to endorse Donald J Trump
this is this is such a backfire in so
many ways so let me give you the back
story of what's going on here NBC news
article Ronde this is from uh six days
ago Ron desantis's team tries to stop
Florida Republicans from endorsing Trump
the governor's team has reached out to
at least six Florida Congressional
Republicans over the past week trying to
stop the bleeding the idea here is as
follows DeSantis hasn't announced yet
he may announce at some point over the
next three to four months is what's for
some reason July keeps being talked
about okay
if a bunch of these Florida Republicans
jump out and endorse Trump right now
it's not great for DeSantis DeSantis is
going to want to build his base of
support with endorsements presumably
starting with a Florida Republicans Greg
stubey decided I'm going to take a stand
I'm going to get in Trump's good graces
I'm going to try to get an atta boy from
Trump so I'm going to proudly go on
Newsmax and announce that I am indeed
endorsing Trump
and then you get his name wrong and not
only do you get it wrong you use an
insulting term chump yeah and Rob I want
to thank you for giving me the
opportunity to talk about this on your
show and I'm happy and honored to
endorse Donald J Trump
this is your big moment to get on
Trump's good side to try to get
attention barely anyone cares what Greg
stewby ever says and you go out there
and you call him a chump now he also
attacked Ron DeSantis and this is where
it starts to get a little bit more
interesting Beyond just the cartoonish
nature of chump
the attacks on DeSantis are also
starting to be coordinated that's that
is one thing that I I hear from a lot of
people that I know I got a lot of
friends in Florida and they they say
that when DeSantis talks about you know
or when they think this hand is going to
run they're mortified because they don't
want to lose him uh in the Sunshine
State
yeah it's uh he hasn't even been elected
re-elected for six months uh and while
we're in legislative session right now
and the state legislature is doing their
business uh he's in South Carolina and
Iowa I think he's up here in Washington
uh tomorrow meeting with people where
his focus should be in Florida uh
Floridians want him to be focused on
Florida that's what he signed up for his
job for reelection to do so this is
telegraphing and predicting what is
going to be a big line of attack from
anti-desantis Republicans they showed us
these cards they showed us that this was
the hand they were going to be playing
even before the election we had clips of
Carrie Lake and Marjorie Taylor green
who by the way want to be Trump's VP
um saying DeSantis needs to do his work
for the people of Florida DeSantis has
been re-elected to be the governor
DeSantis should commit to serving the
full term which DeSantis opted not to do
during his debate uh in the 2022
midterms so this is going to be a line
of attack this is a guy who should be
doing what he told Floridians he was
going to do he is disloyal or he is some
way doing the wrong thing by not staying
and serving his term this is going to be
a line of attack it's abundantly clear
will DeSantis announce I don't know
we'll know very soon
the weather is about to start warming up
and that often means sweating and
chafing and sticking sheath is the men's
underwear that once and for all puts an
end to all of that nonsense our sponsor
sheath underwear has designed unique
boxer briefs with an ergonomic
compartment built to keep everything
separate and dry and cool and
comfortable by allowing air to circulate
everywhere it needs to be no more
readjusting all day sheath offers a huge
variety of designs and patterns over
half a million pairs have already been
sold also check out their super
comfortable bamboo t-shirts sheath has
amazing customer service super fast
shipping along with over twenty thousand
five star reviews sheath is also
actively working with multiple
non-profits that deal with mental health
and homelessness which you support when
you get sheath underwear I've had a
great experience with sheath underwear I
know you will too head on over to
sheathunderwear.com Pacman and use the
code Pacman for 20 off the link is down
below